I don't know why I'm picturing Rocky
punching the meat in the freezer oh no
but it's a woman now she's going ow
ow well she's Frozen
so it hurts you're going out like that
[Music]
anybody here like Arby's
I actually like it it's the unsung hero
of fast food beef sandwiches and the
macros are actually pretty decent two to
one uh protein and fat ratio nice I like
I like the cheddar though then you're in
trouble cheddar oh you gotta stick to
the boat the turkey sandwich is a
freaking surprise really good sandwich
it's just a regular turkey sandwich but
I have Ranch in it it's fantastic boring
all right so out in Louisiana this sock
them so hard yeah what's the thing don't
make me punch him punch him in the
shoulder
oh he does this Ron hits [__] hard
too yeah I would assume so no but like
for his weight extraordinarily hard I
would almost put money on that Ron
probably hits way harder than I do
should we test you I'll punch you in one
arm and then run punch in the other one
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah let's
test it guys
no in Louisiana
this is Arby's right left Louisiana
right Louisiana what does that mean
left or right I think he means North or
South yeah yeah yeah up or down the
police there actually found a woman's
body in the walk-in freezer at the
Arby's restaurant
police said the woman was an employee of
the Arby's restaurant oh Liberia that's
pretty sad man that's [__] I don't
know why I'm picturing Rocky punching
the meat in the freezer oh no but it's a
woman now she's going ow ow well she's
Frozen she's
so it hurts you're going out like that
out yeah so conditioning yeah
so they're investigating these
suspicious death after body was found in
walk-in freezer
um and I think the the another employee
discovered that female deceased in that
cool damn that sucks yeah so there's
really not much to this right now
um even though the death is suspicious
Foul Play is not expected and it may
have been an accident huh when the cops
walk in do they still yell yeah like she
went inside and she got locked in like
that but they but that doesn't happen
anymore like really you just don't walk
you can open from the inside out maybe
it didn't update their freezer it's
Louisiana though maybe they're not maybe
not yeah left Louisiana or right yeah
North yeah
that's a that's a way to go huh yeah
terrible way to go now [__] this article
why does that die slowly like do you
just pass out because there's lack of
oxygen you're not gonna die from
freezing first I think it's from the
freezing yeah Leonardo DiCaprio yeah it
was like it's floating to the bottom
those two VHS tapes yeah but everybody
else was already dead he was just super
you know what I mean like if it was a
freezer
so it's like sub 32 degrees
how fast how long does it take to die in
a freezer it does take I think I don't
think too long I think like half a day
maybe depends on maybe your body mass
too less than half a day for sure have
you ever you know the uh the Costco
section where you get produce it's so
cold it's cold
oh it's so close it's so cold like try
to be in the fridge in an hour
you know what I mean that one has oxygen
I I was thinking she was dying from
Suffocation before oh yeah man dude yeah
I hope she slipped hit her head knocked
out and done this says uh when I Google
it how long can a human survive in a
home freezer it would take about four
hours to suffocate
should slow your metabolism and extend
the period due to lower oxygen uses oh
so that takes even longer so it just
hurts more for a longer period of time
you're probably fraught by all that [__]
right I also hear that like people think
that it it gets extra cold but it
actually gets hot like the burn the
burning sensor freezer burn because it's
so cold right oh yeah it's like taking
an ice bath I'm such a [__] when it
comes to ice bath ice baths it's so cold
dude you want to know a crazy ass story
that I just remember that happened to my
ex's brother or uh he no this is a
different one he he lives in Colorado
and he got in a fight with a bouncer at
a club and then the bouncers took him to
the back alley and they beat his ass
right and one of them hit him on the
head with a flashlight oh my God and it
basically like
um knocked him out and he knocked out in
the snow he like ran away and knocked
out in the snow
and because he passed out in the ice
it saved his life because this he got a
brain hemorrhage and it didn't swell oh
wow kept the swelling down yeah very
nice so by the time like they found him
they were able to save him because of
that wow and he sued that club and that
dude never has to work again wow
that's a crazy crazy the Mystic story
yeah but it was it's all thanks to the
fact that it snowed that night
if it didn't he'd be dead damn that's
[__] crazy yeah why'd you say dead
like that he'd be good
that's a Denver kind of dead sounds like
Mike's long story that happened to Mike
remember I think he might have been
living with you at the time he's
performing that Blues on the show and
then there was like a moment where he
was like jumping off the stairs in like
the back area but there was like a low
hitting bar and he like jumped off of it
and hit the [__] out of this bar on top
so he was like running around backstage
I think he's supposed to perform with
like culture shock or some [__] he's
like running around there's like blood
down his face oh my God eventually goes
home this is when uh he was still living
in that college house I think it was
Darnell who was the one who ended up
being like coming home you know not in
the dancing seeing Mike in his bed and
like yo man how's your day he's like
dude [__] was crazy man I [__] was at
this show and then I dropped it hit my
head blah blah Darnell was like
but let me see and he looks at him Mike
all he did was put like towels on it or
like a handkerchief or something but he
like opened it up and it was like
full-on bloody bleeding like contusion
like in his head he's like dude you got
to go to the doctor so that he forced
him to go to urgent care at that moment
it's late at night and the same thing
the doctor was like you would have bled
out if you went to sleep
Darnell saved his life I feel like with
any type of head injury you gotta take
that seriously especially if there's
that much blood
the fact that he didn't go immediately
but like people sometimes aren't aware
like maybe you can like uh manage the
pain but you don't think about what
happens when you sleep true yeah that's
true
that just happened to my dad-in-law like
I don't know why everything's been
happening in the past few weeks but uh
he thought he had a stroke like I think
two or three weeks ago he went to the
hospital
um but he had it like the night before
he's like almost he's just brushing his
teeth and he fell to the floor and his
legs didn't work so we had to crawl back
to his bed but he's like uh I'm just
gonna sleep it off
yeah old school he slept it off and then
he called he's like hey son I'm like
what's up Dad what's going on he's like
hey I think I got a stroke I was like
right now he's like no last night he's
like what he's like I'm gonna call the
I'm gonna call the ambulance I'm like
yeah call him right now and then they
took him the ambulance and then ran a
bunch of tests and stuff like that did
he have a stroke he ended up getting
vertigo
yeah better than the stroke and then so
now he's on medication and he's not
allowed to drive for Wow vertigo can
make your legs not work dude Virgo's
[__] up yes apparently there's
crystals in your ear that mess with your
equilibrium and they make it so you
can't see your stand straight or
something yeah it's like the depth
perception I think dudes are done though
because I remember you know when we
still have the other JK office I used to
it was routine for me to like work out
and then shower there because I had we
had showers there and one day I had like
the most excruciating pain I've ever
felt like in my side where I just
collapse on the floor and it was I was
like oh what the [__] and it felt like
um you know when you get kicked in the
nuts like the pain is there and you
can't make it go away no matter what it
felt like that and it felt like I was
about to be in tears and then I'm like
oh [__] I'm just gonna die you know
because I was by myself my mom's gonna
[__] die here and then and then it
went it went away he's so accepting yeah
and then this is it I finished my shower
and I just I just went on with the day
I didn't tell anybody I probably should
have just like
gone to the doctor or whatever but yeah
it goes away and you're like oh good
okay this is way better did you ever
figure out what it was no no I don't
know what it could be like [__]
kidney stones or something but maybe
yeah maybe you just rapidly passed the
stone what do you think maybe you just
passed a stone like is that how that
works yeah it could be is the kidneys
even on this side because it could take
forever or it could just like there's
two right yeah I don't even know but it
hurt like crazy it was like he's like
the one thing that usually they think it
might be is your appendix but if it
didn't if it bursts you would be dead it
was the craziest pit at first in my
adult life died from a penis oh that's
the craziest yeah pretty common I think
oh Smith yeah and I just was like
afterwards I was like okay that's cool
dude that's that's crazy to go from you
really are accepting that this is oh and
then the other one and
crazy uh remember I was training for the
marathon yeah so um we all were I think
I think we all were actually I actually
think I got robbed though so in one of
the training sessions so I'm on Tuesdays
and Thursdays uh I would drive to the
office to write with Steve and Joe and I
remember
um to make it we always meet at nine but
the Those runs were still starting
longer and longer they're like seven
miles nine eleven thirteen whatever so
pretty soon
like in order to make it to the office
at nine I have to wake up at three or
four in the morning to run four hours
before I shower or whatever and I
remember one time I was gonna rush I was
like oh I've been running faster today
so I was running like way faster than my
normal pace and I'm driving down on the
605 and I just start breaking out and
sweats and I had a [__] fever and
then I thought my my calf cramping and
then it was scary because I would press
on the accelerator I'm like oh [__] so
I'm like I'm trying to like oh [__] I'm
like let me move my leg to the side and
then [__] drive with my left foot now
and then and then I like pulled over and
I'm like oh well this is [__] crazy
and I was sitting in that truck the car
and I was just sweating and then I'm
like
this is it
this is how I go
oh I think okay I think I went away
[Music]